joining us now is the governor of Texas
and great to have you here with us sir
um can you explain what did you decide
was the breaking point for you to take
the steps that you did and maybe also
just back up and let people know what
are you saying about the compact between
the federal government and the state of
Texas
today so it was the states that created
the United States and when the states
voted to uh create the United States and
have a constitution uh included in that
agreement was the compact that the
federal government would take care of
the states and article 4 section four of
the Constitution speaks to that and and
says that if the federal government does
not take care of the states the states
are endangered we can ask the federal
government to live up to his obligation
then the authors of the Constitution
knew there would be times when the
federal government would not live up to
his duty and so they empowered States in
Article 1 Section 10 the right of
self-defense and what Texas is asserting
is our Article 1 Section 10 right of
self-defense because the president of
the United States is not fulfilling his
duty to enforce the laws passed by
Congress that deny illegal entry into
the United States governor will you
instruct your officers to physically
prevent Federal officers from accessing
that part of the
border so uh what Texas is doing is just
very simple and and that is because the
Biden Administration has really truly
abdicated its responsibility to secure
the border and enforce the laws tesas
very simply is securing the border and
so we put up the razor wire that you
were talking about Bill and we put up
all these barricades that actually have
denied illegal entry and as you pointed
out also in that screening that there
are criminals coming across our border
Texas has a right as a state to stop
criminals from coming into our state to
make arrest of those criminals and we
have National Guard as well as Texas
Department of Public Safety officers who
are there to make those arrests and to
deny illegal entry and Joe Biden
actually does have an option here Joe
Biden's option is to enforce the laws of
the United States and stop this illegal
entry and look like they're going to do
that listen to Karen Jean Pierre this is
what she said about you yesterday it's
unfortunate that there is a governor in
Texas governor Abbott who has
politicized this issue of what's
happening on the border and it's not
making people's lives safer it's
actually making it harder for law
enforcement at the at the border to do
their job she that that she actually she
just said that this morning how do you
respond well obviously it's a very
uninformed comment on her part there's
really only one person in America not
doing their job and that's the president
of the United States who's not enforcing
immigration laws also as she has already
been called out and the president and
other Democrats and media uh they have
cast a false narrative about some people
dying on the border that apparently
Texas denied border patrol access to has
been completely debunked the only thing
that the spokesperson for Biden can do
is to cast aspersions and lies hoping
that people will believe them because
the truth of the matter is what Texas is
doing is what Americans expect to be
done Americans expect the border to be
secured because Joe Biden has abandoned
that responsibility Texas is stepping up
and doing it with all that razor wire
that you're showing right now and you've
committed to putting up more razor wire
where the US Supreme Court just a few
days ago said that the feds are allowed
to cut through the wire that you've been
watching yourself for a couple years now
and just to go back to your first answer
that you mentioned there this was your
statement yesterday the federal
government has broken the compact
between the United States and the states
uh the executive branch in the United
States is a constitutional duty to
enforce federal laws protecting States
including immigration laws on the books
right now so if you lost this week at
the US Supreme Court does this now go
back there and how would you expect to
win a second time
around sure one quick point of
clarification uh something bill you just
said that everybody's saying uh and that
is that the Supreme Court you said the
Supreme Court said what Texas cannot do
if you look at what the Supreme Court
actually issued they didn't write any
type of opinion all they did was to
vacate a fifth Circuit Court of Appeals
order and to send it back to the FIS
court of appeals it's two sentences
there there was no opinion about
anything about razor wire or what Texas
is doing or anything like that uh and
but that point
aside regardless of what federal statute
may exist the supremacy the supremacy
claw means that the constitution itself
is the supreme law of the land the
Constitution itself provides Texas with
a right of self-defense in this case
because the United States has abandoned
its responsibility to defend Texas so if
you can get this case on the Merit to
the Supreme Court you could
win so Dan first uh now I think maybe we
will get it to the fifth circuit on its
merits right where I believe we can win
and I do believe that when we get to the
Supreme Court we can win we already I I
don't know how and why the justices
voted the way they did but there seem to
be four justices who indicated at least
an appetite to hear the case as is a
fair point is the the case that was
presented to to the United States
Supreme Court actually did not have very
much of a record upon which a an appell
Court can actually make a decision so
those who may not have voted in favor of
Texas or let's say those who voted to
send it back to the fif circuit they may
have thought in their mind that there's
not enough record for them to make a
decision but we don't know that Dana and
this is very important again because
there was there were no sentences or
paragraphs or pages of an opinion
written by the Supreme Court so no one
knows at all what they were thinking all
we know is they wanted to send it back
to the fif circuit Governor I know you
were just overseas in India but I know
you paid attention in New Hampshire the
other night what the exit polling told
us and the entrance polling and our
voter analysis said immigration is topic
number one we saw it in Iowa we saw it
New Hampshire so Americans are thinking
about this okay and I I'm curious about
sort of the Shadow story here that a lot
of people don't talk about and that is
what the administration's doing with
Mexico uh and this has been going on for
some time maybe a month maybe more than
that between Anthony blinkin uh and the
president's deputies coming to
Washington DC do you believe this
Administration is ready and prepared to
to change policy at the Border in an
election year with 10 months to spare
that would make the issue less potent
for Democrats come
November it it's it's hard for me to
tell uh what's going on uh what is clear
is that Joe Biden has from the time he
took off as he actually during the time
that he was campaigning he had no intent
to secure the Border he talked about
open border policies during the campaign
and now he's allowed open border
policies with kly most Americans not
even knowing what that meant but now the
people in New York knows what it means
now the people in Chicago knows what it
means people across the country are
having to experience what open borders
mean bill I'll tell you this most
incumbents don't lose elections they get
fired and they get fired because they're
doing a bad job as you talked about the
immigration system and the Border issue
is the primary issue in America right
now this is an issue upon which Joe
Biden gets a grade of F and deserves to
be fired Governor Greg Abbott thank you
for joining us today we appreciate it
and we'll stay in
touch thank you all take care I'm Steve
duy I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart
and click here to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis